Welcome back to recitation.
In this video I would like us
to do the following problem.
We're going to let z
equal x squared plus y
and we want S to
be the graph of z
above the unit square
in the xy-plane.
And what we'd like to do is
for F equal to z*i plus x*k,
find the upward
flux of F through S.
So S is our surface
that's a graph,
over the xy-plane
and the unit square,
of z equal to x squared plus y.
And we want to compute
the upward flux of F
through that surface.
So why don't you work on this
problem, pause the video,
and then when you're
ready to see my solution,
bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
So again, what we
want to do is we want
to find the upward flux of
F through this surface S.
And let's think about first, how
do we describe the surface S?
S is the graph of z
equal x squared plus y.
So we can think of
it as, z is really--
we can think of it as a function
of x and y over the unit
square.
So we can say f of x,
y is equal to z which
is equal to x squared plus y.
And then we know how to
compute the normal-- well,
we know how to compute
n*dS, which also in class is
sometimes written notationally
as dS with the vector dS.
So we know how to compute
this form right here.
And it is-- you were shown in
class that if f is-- or sorry.
If you have a graph, if
your surface is a graph,
then this is exactly equal to
the vector minus f sub x comma
minus f sub y comma 1 dx dy.
So that's exactly what this
n*dS-- so n is the vector,
and dS is the surface
form we have here.
So n*dS is exactly equal to
the vector minus f sub x,
minus f sub y, 1, dx dy.
So what do we have
here with f sub x?
f sub x-- because f is
equal to z-- f sub x is 2x
and f sub y is 1.
So in our case we get
exactly minus 2x, comma
minus 1, comma 1, dx dy.
And now to compute the surface
integral what we do-- or sorry,
to compute the flux along
the surface, what we do
is we integrate over
the surface-- which
I guess we should remember
that's a double integral,
because it's over a surface--
of F dotted with dS.
But that's the same as
integrating over the region.
So we have this surface,
we know the region
below that defines the
surface in the xy-coordinates.
So it's integrating over
the region of F dotted
with this vector here.
Because n*dS-- dS is n*dS,
and in the x-y components
it's exactly equal to this.
Minus 2x, minus 1, 1, dx dy.
So now we're integrating.
We've gone from looking
at a surface integral.
Now we're integrating--
we were integrating F dot
dS on the surface,
to now taking F
dotted with this
vector on the region
in the xy-plane over
which we can define S.
So the region we're
interested in, remember,
is the unit square.
So we have the unit square
which is x goes from 0 to 1
and y goes from 0 to 1.
And then what we're
doing is we're
looking at F as a
function of x, y, and z.
And we want to dot
that with this vector.
And it's all being done
in the variables x and y.
So we should be able to
change everything to x and y
ultimately.
So let's look at what
we get when we do that.
So F-- I'm going
to remind myself--
F was equal to z*i plus x*k.
Which, if I write that
in the component form,
it's z comma, 0 comma, x.
So F dotted with our minus
f sub x, minus f sub y, 1--
which was minus 2x, minus
1, 1-- we see we get--
minus 2x dotted with z-- we get
minus 2x*z and then we get 0
and then we get x.
So we get minus 2x*z plus x.
That's exactly what f dotted
with the vector we have is.
So now also, we know that z
was equal to x squared plus y.
So we actually get negative 2x
times x squared plus y plus x
again.
So I'm going to just expand that
so it's easier to deal with.
So we get negative 2x
cubed minus 2x*y plus x.
And now we have exactly
what-- if we look over here--
we have exactly this
entire part here written
as a function of x and y.
Which is good.
Why is that good?
Because everything we're
integrating is in x and y.
We're doing dx and dy so we just
need to figure out the bounds
and compute the integral.
So let's come over here.
So the flux then is going
to be equal to-- well,
we know the region.
We know the region is y and
x are both going from 0 to 1.
So the order doesn't
matter because nothing
depends on another function.
And then we're integrating
exactly this function.
Negative 2 x to the third
minus 2x*y plus x dy dx.
So when we integrate in
y, we should be careful,
what do we get here?
We're going to have the
integral from 0 to 1,
and then we're going to have--
this we get a negative 2 x
cubed times y, and then
evaluated at 0 and 1,
so we just get a
negative 2 x cubed again.
We integrate this we have a
negative 2x y squared over 2.
So at 0 we get nothing
and at 1 we get 1/2.
And so we get minus 2x.
And then here when we integrate
in y, we get x times y
and we evaluate that at 1 and
0, and we got just plus x.
So let me just make sure I
didn't make any mistakes there.
So this one, I'm
integrating it in y
and so I get a negative 2 x
cubed y, evaluated at 0 and 1.
So at 1 I just get a negative
2 x cubed, at 0 I get 0.
In this one, I have
a negative 2x*y.
When I integrate that I
get a y squared over 2.
The 2s kill off.
So I'm left with a
negative of x y squared.
Evaluating that at 0
and 1, at 0 I get 0
and at 1 I get negative x.
Oh, there.
So there shouldn't be a 2 there.
And then here, when I integrate
that I get x*y evaluated at y
equals 0 and y equals 1,
and take that difference.
And at 1 I get just x
and at 0 I get nothing.
Hopefully that one
is correct now.
Because I forgot to kill
off the 2 there first.
So those subtract off and I'm
left with minus the integral
from 0 to 1 of 2 x cubed dx.
Well, that's going to
be minus of x cubed,
it's going to be x
to the fourth over 4.
And then I have
the 2 still here.
So that will divide out.
Evaluate at 0 and 1.
At 0 I obviously get nothing.
At 1 I get negative 1/2.
And so the flux of
F across the surface
is equal to negative 1/2.
And that's the upward flux.
So obviously if I wanted
to know the downward flux,
that would be positive 1/2.
It doesn't have anything
to do with what F is.
It has to do with the
direction of the normal
that I'm dotting F with.
So since I was dotting F
with the upward normal--
which is the n*dS that I showed
you was the upward normal--
then I know that this
is the upward flux.
So let me just remind
you what we did here.
Let's come back to
the very beginning.
So the object was that we had
z as a function of x and y.
So we knew we had
a surface sitting
over some region
in the xy-plane.
And we wanted to compute
the flux of a certain vector
field-- the upward flux of
a certain vector field--
across that surface.
And so all we had to do to solve
this problem was ultimately
understand what n*dS was--
which you actually did in class.
You saw what n*dS is, this
is the upward normal through
the surface.
And then recognize
that the flux-- again,
we saw this from class-- that
the flux is equal to the double
integral over the
surface of F dot dS,
which is the same as the double
integral over the region of F
dotted with n*dS.
Where n*dS, now, I'm referring
to as-- n is the vector and dS
is-- this whole component is
n*dS-- that's what we found.
And so then we know F. It's
in terms of z, x, and y.
But then we can find
it in terms of x and y.
When we take that dot product
we end up with exactly just
a function of x and y, when we
replace z by what it actually
is equal to.
And then we just
compute the integral.
And this is just a regular
old double integral.
And we get the flux
was equal to minus 1/2.
And again, I want to point
out that if we wanted instead
of the upward flux
the downward flux,
it would be the same
with the opposite sign.
OK.
That is where I think I'll stop.